Dark Souls has many unseen lands places
out of bounds or out of time that we've
never seen until now we received over
200 entries from artists all over the
world and these are the places they
chose then from all of these entries ten
artists depicting these seven lands
ended up making it into the top ten and
you'd think the hardest part of all this
would be deciding who came first but man
that's actually always the easy part the
hard part is actually deciding who comes
11th 12 13th the runner-ups always come
so close to making it into the top 10
but there's always just this amazing
group that only just miss out so what
you're seeing right now are actually the
12 runners-up that I've chosen but only
one of them can get 10th place so let me
show them to you and share this pain
with you and also teach you a little bit
about the ranking criteria for this
competition in terms of technical skill
these four entries were amazing
we have Oliver's black church of wand or
alesandro's Kareem Martens Kareem and
Benjamin's citadel of sentosa
unfortunately some of these weren't very
rounded entries and we ended up deciding
that world-building is going to be a
really important factor in this
competition so stronger in the
world-building aspect were kayo Santos's
Karthus and Rubens mafia which both
possessed really powerful mood or
atmosphere and in order to weight
world's building more heavily I added
another criteria story because visual
storytelling can help you feel grounded
in an image and Jonases Melfi a-- was an
excellent example of this he has these
buildings made from the remainders of
ships upon which the refugees of Malviya
once sailed to this land originality was
another category it highlights the
importance of expanding these worlds not
just relying on what the game has
already told us vincent's Malviya was a
great example of this as it really
doubled down
an astrological theme and there were two
entries for the great swamp that come to
mind as well Zach's Tree of Life entry
had me curious about this giant egg and
Daniel's City built within a crab is
really thinking outside the box we loved
it and finally there's presentation
Felix contributed a wonderfully detailed
vision of New Londo and its flaming sons
and Holdsworth hands our resident pixel
art animation guy presented a charming
little slice of Londo so which of these
would you give tenth place to it's so
tough if you disagree go and give your
support to the artists that you think
deserved it I hope you understand how
hard this is and believe my sincere
congratulations when we award 10th place
to Vincent
Letang zelphia in Dark Souls elfia is a
nation that becomes heavily influenced
by sorcery pyromancy and astrology but
Vincent goes all in on the astrology
theme lending an originality and depth
to his piece that helped him stand out
from the competition as he tells it Mel
fears inhabitants settled on a
mountaintop to avoid the thick sea of
fog below but over the years noticed a
strange light in the valley periodically
a light beam would pierce the clouds and
illuminate a lake fusing with the waters
and creating a substance called star
jelly the properties of this substance
obsessed the astrologists leading to the
construction of a huge observatory and
research into its properties began with
a refinement humans could drink the
nectar which many became hopelessly
addicted to leading to a swath of the
population forced to assuage their
hunger with the astral waste that left
the sewers I would have loved to see
more of the addict enemies roaming the
observatory and more of the culture that
must exist up on the mountaintops so
while it lost a couple of points for
that it is a testament to the strength
of this piece that it leaves you hooked
hungry for more
another really original entry was
Brent's rendition of Corrine which stood
out to us immediately
thanks to
attractive color palette there were a
lot of Kareem entries like a lot and
it's probably because the place actually
has a rare amount of visual imagery to
draw from a mourns great hammer for
example is said to be decorated by a
ward of Kareem temple so a lot of
artists modeled their architecture after
the hammer furthermore morn's black
armor with its gargoyle helm is very
gothic so a lot of artists decided to
depict a grim Gothic style city to match
the grim countenance of its people
these artists didn't lose points for
doing that in fact those entries are
probably really accurate but I do have
to give a few more points for
originality to Brent who depicted
Kareem's atmosphere and culture with a
more vibrant mood in order to better
represent Kareem before it descended
into a darker more depraved place
however I really liked that for the keen
observer subtle hints of Kareem's grim
flavour to remain note the begging woman
in the dark the hanging corpses in the
town square and note that almost every
person in this image is armed and on
guard in that way the piece kind of
throws a curveball to the viewer making
it way more exciting to explore in both
images your eyes are drawn towards
important story points in the first
towards the archbishop who descends the
stairs in a palanquin to highlight his
importance and in a second to a statue
of kaya the weeping goddess who looms
over the city with a giant bowl beneath
her like a Lourdes vessel except this
one functions as a symbolic asset to
catch her tears next we travel to loot
Luntz home a place called coland or
what's left of it anyway
we only know a couple of things about
corland first that they were plagued by
a beast called the soul feeder which
insatiably absorbed Souls and whose
corpse permanently stained the air when
it was burned second we know that their
people had a fascination with
transposition which is the forbidden art
of
extracting and coalescing the essence of
a soul Robert takes these concepts and
he runs off with them depicting a place
once blooming with wonders now filled
with corpses and curses in the first of
his supporting images he depicted sturer
the cursed city where you can still see
the soul feeder smoldering where they
burned him the city bridge here stands
over the soulless swamp where soulless
husks prey on those who enter it and
branching off from here is an entry to
the soul cavern where a few soul
harvesters still reside apparently
there's also something called the
ancient bonfire shrine here which I love
because it hints that bonfires which
aren't explained very much in game that
they might hide a sinister truth his
main image is the soul Cathedral which
is the most developed image of the bunch
the mood here is just incredible and
when you think about it Dark Souls is
kind of missing a land with a ghostly
haunted soul harvesting kind of vibe and
what better place for this than coland
appearing in the top 10 for the third
competition in a row is Jonathan Lee and
whenever he contributes it's rare that
anyone beats him in terms of technical
skill the visual perspective he's chosen
here is excellent it has this angle that
draws the viewers eye up the stairs into
the courtyard onto the cathedral and
then up and out of the hole in the roof
of course this is New Londo before it
was flooded and Jonathan's talent for
lighting is able to be used to its
fullest extent here thanks to that hole
in the roof which casts this sort of
melancholy silhouette on the entire
scene this sort of lighting is such a
signature part of new Londos design and
it plays the supporting role for the
entire image here the four kings stand
proud over the viewer seeing off this
cult-like procession of sealers who
march away from the main cathedral and
if you look closely at the base of the
statues you'll kind of notice a mossy
damp ground which could be a bit of
foreshadowing for new lenders flooded
fate while it would have loved to see
some original storytelling here to take
new Londos origins to new depths this is
a faithful scene it's perfectly executed
and it's worthy of seventh place at the
very least jonathan contributed a second
land to this competition which wasn't
recommended but we partly took it into
account it's a depiction of Ferren
before it's full sent into a depraved
swampland and it's a refreshing
uplifting view of that terrible swamp
taking us back to Courland for number
six Pierre presents his take on the city
submitting sixteen pieces in total and
overwhelming the competition with sheer
volume he splits his submission into
four areas each depicting a section of
the city that you'll visit on your
descent deep down below the clouds you
arrive first at Colin's hidden access
point nestled between two clouded
mountaintops here you're introduced to
the character and as he walks inside you
get a sense that this city has long
since suffered a cursed fate the light
has troubled piercing the cloud cover so
the actual city itself is bathed in a
greenish hue but there are flames
burning deep within which is a bit of
foreshadowing for what's to come
as I pressed forward I realized that the
main character here is actually super
important for grounding the piece
because it's a consistent element that
takes you through the descent far below
in the room of the great kill you're
supposed to fight Ciel the guard
commander of courland and its strongest
knight who defends a powerful
transposing kiln and defends the plaza
where the sole feeder was executed and
of all the places for bosses to be
acceptable coal and qualifies as one of
the precious little things we know about
the place is the existence of the soul
feeder which
let's be honest would be a boss this
final boss fight takes place in coland
plaza against a croc the sole feeder who
was never really dead but instead simply
awaits a powerful soul that will help
him to regain his power now while
contributing more pieces to this
competition sort of increases the scope
and the roundedness of your entry you're
also increasing the pressure on yourself
to make sure that every image has enough
detail to be worthy of submission the
city did feel a little bit empty which
gave at some points for mood and
atmosphere since that does match the
story but some images were a little bit
devoid of details and we would have
loved some tidbits that could have
expanded the story even further because
that's one thing we want to reinforce is
that sometimes it only takes one image
to place highly in this competition and
this couldn't be more true than for
Nolan's rendition of Katarina
which knocks it out of the park for mood
for story and for originality Katarina
is described as a jovial country
brimming with drink and cheer and to
best represent this Nolan made this
really clever decision to show a
Katarina and dungeon of all places you'd
think such a place would be grim and
depressing filled with criminals but no
instead the main cells are usually just
filled with those involved in drunken
scuffles from the night before and
hungover nights often receive plenty of
loud musical visits from friends to lift
their spirits while the lower levels are
reserved for rare cases of serious crime
or for assassins from other regions the
dungeon is in the open air it's right
next to the town square and the onion
stalls where the general public is free
to come and go in this square we see one
such criminal being plucked from the
streets by a strong relaxed Knight as he
waves to a character behind him is he
waving to the imprisoned Knight raising
his seat brow in Cheers or the chef
doling out stew to a hungry prisoner
perhaps he's even waving to the young
boy who sports a wide bowl on his head
to mimic the onion-shaped helmets of the
Knights that he clearly admires it could
be any one of them and it's a great
excuse to just look at all the character
that is on display here the
world-building is so powerful I can kind
of imagine the rest of the city streets
just from this one image that's the
power of storytelling really and it
doesn't need any other supporting images
but Nolan did decide to show the outside
view of the city which sports curved
rooftops that mimic the Pierce shield
that the Knights commonly wield Nolan's
technical skills are impressive they
show a confident control of lighting and
Anatomy I particularly love the momentum
of the knight plucking the assassin of
the streets for example I only wish
there was a bit more effort put into
presentation and refinement as it is a
painting of crude strokes and a few
details do seem to be missing but
regardless this image was a joy to
review bringing the atmosphere to a
different place entirely with Zen clouds
interpretation of jugo which places
forth in this competition central to the
culture of this desert land arts giant
ants whose enormous ant hills surround
the region item descriptions read that
he who recklessly enters an anthill will
surely have their flesh melted to the
bone but the risk is apparently worth
the reward for many seek to collect
their corrosive acid or their larvae
which are considered a delicacy Zen
expands this concept beautifully with
this haunting fascinating wasteland let
me zoom in and give you a better sense
of scale and story in Zen's jugo these
tall abandoned ant hills make up the
city itself with high rooms for the
richest citizens as these are the safest
from ant invasions the city is connected
with ropes and pulleys which enable
aerial transport of citizens and the
goods that they produce so the second
tallest section makes up the artisan
quarter where powder from the chitinous
carapace --is of ants
ground and used in production of goods
and most notably it's used in the
compound that's used to create Oris or
which is a curious transparent metal
named after its Discoverer whose armor
takes on its unique properties further
down is a school dedicated to pyromancy
which is taught at an early age as
protection against ant invasions also
taken at an early age are some ants
themselves which apparently can be tamed
if they're taken from their colony at
the moment that they're born grounding
the image in the bottom left is a rider
mounted on one such end and he's braving
the desert and guiding his mount with a
piece of meat hanging from a stick he's
out here to collect ant larvae something
that can only be done on the rare days
that the Sun is not blocked by a
sandstorm so this is a rare time where
you can see the city and it's the best
time for traveling and scavenging so one
hilarious thing happened with all the
jugo entries when talking about jugo in
my announcement video we had to decide
on how to visually represent the ant
hills and because there are no ant hills
represented in dark souls 2 my editor
decided to represent them by showing the
tall pillars that you see just after you
defeat the guardian dragon bossfight in
dark souls 2 well almost every artist
who decided to draw jugo either loved
the striking imagery of the super tall
vertical ant hills or they thought that
these were actually the ant hills from
jugo and chose to represent them in that
way no one just drew a normal ant hill
which i thought was hilarious
either way it's actually enhanced all of
the jugo entries in my opinion and it's
a funny unintentional side effect of the
original video coming in at third place
is owns artwork titled the fall of New
Londo
he begins and ends his story with a view
of this restored New Londo Cathedral
your view then descends down to the city
streets where mankind from all across
the realm gather these are the folks
that will lose their lives when the
sealers decide to flood the city to
contain the four kings so there's
already some bittersweet story going on
just by seeing this bustling marketplace
but then the next scene begins and you
feel the gravity of this piece improve
Gwyn is walking past the common folk and
he's holding a piece of his soul the
view pans back up again to better show
his Vanguard of knights and the curious
onlookers who have now been pushed aside
Gwyn approaches the four kings who sport
this faithful representation of the
armor that will one day become twisted
and corrupted and then he Huddle's with
them to better share his soul with those
who were supposed to be the best of
mankind while it lacks a little bit in
originality it makes up for that in all
of the other categories it presented a
powerful story by simply arranging these
scenes in the right order and the mood
of this event is powerful to any player
who has played these games it's
wonderful to be able to visualize a
scene that we know must have happened
but never see in game and it's a
meaningful representation of the city
that it takes place within ohm's
portfolio expands his wonderful talent
for environments and one of my favorite
sets of his was his depiction of a
desert world which had a lot of
parallels with the angles that he chose
for his new londo piece he states that
he's looking for full-time employment
contract and freelance work so if you're
in a position to employ him or any of
the artists on this list for that matter
please reach out and now second place
this location made up 10% of total
submissions to this competition it's a
grim land of knights and maidens of
tears and sin land ruled by depraved
Lords who stand under the ominous watch
of Velka the goddess of sin and kayfa
the goddess of tears or perhaps these
two women are one and the same
and deep below in their crypt yet
another painted world exists where all
the lords fears are locked away
this is kareem by Jane
the first part of her illustration
depicts a historic moment in Kareem's
culture every year she writes the chosen
maiden and her night are blessed by the
archbishop before departing to other
lands to spread word of their faith this
time of course its arena and aegon and
behind them are members of their
respective castes others who train
diligently for the same honors that are
being bestowed upon them
Jane has hidden tons of wonderful
details in this image from the crows
that represent Velka to the statues that
reflect their culture and the color red
that represents the blood that is ready
to be shed in the name of the way of
white she's even gone as far as to
depict what this place would look like
in game replete with an area map and all
of the items and NPCs that you'll
encounter within and all of this effort
is mirrored once more
quite literally mirrored below in the
crypts of velka which is designed to be
juxtaposed against the cathedral above
where above there were flying petals
here there are flying ashes above warm
colors below cold and in the center a
worshipper facing volka not an
archbishop facing the people this is the
place full of things that Kareem was
trying to hide things like purging
stones sinners and Felker's twisted
worshippers at the bottom of the mural
are the sinners the guilty who are the
lowest and furthest from Velka then
there are the followers of Velka who
have turned their faith toward her but
not yet with the devotion that would
start to turn them into crows on a
physical level these are the messengers
an angelic depiction of the beings that
became the crow demons in-game and
beyond them there's the enlightened who
have completely abandoned their sinful
mortal forms and have become crows
entirely as you can probably tell by now
we love when pieces contain really good
world building in the little details and
this piece really is replete with them
from the thorns as a universal symbol of
sin there's velka's tears which hint
towards the rumors that she and the
goddess of tears are one in the same
there's even a man who
looks suspiciously like chester in the
foreground and it wouldn't be surprising
to find him here of all places
speaking of which it's not out of place
at all to have a painted world here as
well especially with all of Kareem's
references to crows and Velka so that's
exactly what Jane's drawn just like the
outside world and its endless cycles
painted worlds too are said to rise and
fall and this rendition of Aria nor is
very welcome in her submission because
it expands the world of Kareem it
doesn't just show us what we already
know Jane is an artist from Ukraine
working in game development to provide
2d and 3d concepts for games so she has
this mixed style of presentation which
must be a really attractive prospect for
any of her employers as it really does
help with your visualization to have 2d
and 3d presentation so this piece that
I've been showing on screen is her
submission for another art challenge
where she combines King Arthur legends
with familiar Dark Souls inspired
characters you should go check it out
the portfolio is incredibly gripping and
now for first place
when I showed you the chart at the start
of the video showing how many
contributions there were for each land
you might have noticed one lonely
category izalith it's not the first
place you would think of as an unseen
land but anyone with really deep
knowledge of the law knows that this is
a civilization that has largely been
erased by the time that we explore it in
Dark Souls and there was once rich
history and culture within this untamed
city so with great pride I'd like to
take you through the dawn and dusk of
the age of chaos by Ricardo amici I
remember very vividly the last day
father and I went to visit my godmother
we were invited to see the new temple
complex down below our beloved capital a
path leads through the realm of chaos
where her reign once began and ever
since the thick air was set ablaze her
most grotesque spawn have wandered
aimlessly then from the dark the mortals
came crawling out of the woodwork
in the search for light and although
most of the giant creatures were barely
able to subsist these monsters quickened
the most primordial fears of the mortals
and out of fear they worshipped them
each of their kind bore the name of
another fear but there was one name that
would apply to the more demons
throughout their coexistence the wildest
architecture emerged built without order
one upon the other never lasting ever
changing I stayed close to father's garb
for he was my guiding light through the
maze of absurdity and for every step
that echoed through the hallways
ceilings stretching high as the sky's
vault another thousand eyes stared back
from the dark I could tell by their
dazzled glance that they had never seen
the Sun rise upon their dusty land and
although they were not fortunate enough
to know the order of an everyday life
they all seemed to share a common goal
from afar
whispered a promise to end their
miserable frailty and so the new temple
to
the destination of their pilgrimage no
one understood the nature of the flame
as well as my godmother did when we
climbed the world she stayed behind so
she could conduct research where the
first fire sprouted with her bare hands
she dug a deep down all the way to the
tips of the arch trees root system where
she believed she'd find the spark of
life and so it was here that she built
her kingdom to become one with it over
time her cult of followers grew for they
all craved godhood she taught her wealth
of knowledge to her scholars and thus
her Academy of fire arts became one of
the three great schools of power we
entered the new temple that was still
under construction but already an
uncountable amount of kneeling aspirants
gathered before the structure to solicit
their favors or seeking the flame like
moths ready to burn themselves in the
process their soft murmur was
interrupted by the welcoming ceremonies
we were received in audience by the
first high priest to ever learn the
eloquence of chaos in honor of our
arrival we were to witness a play of
tribal fire arts with the understanding
of their most primal emotions they were
flameless to fire storms and back again
in a most rhythmic fervor it almost
looked like they ardently fought one
another with my yet young eyes I did not
see the most obvious demonstration of
power that took place right before me
the priests guided us we descended
further and entered a chamber they
called the womb many years had passed
since construction began and word of her
work had preceded her I was eager to see
the kingdom she built but soon I would
find all my fantasies of lustrous
banquets with new cousins to make
friends with dwindle but she would never
be the same after she dared look behind
the curtain of our existence but for the
first time I got to see her infamous son
he was a [ __ ] but nowhere close to
the malformed abomination had imagined
from the
rumors of bad mouthed uncles her face
was set and grim she must have known
father did not come in good faith he
stood before her his bright presence
unveiling all her darkest deeds he
pointed his finger starting on his left
swaying across the whole room to his
right questioning everything in his path
why did the arch priest skin bear scales
why would she bestow the gift of fire
upon the mortals and how did she not see
the impurity of her son suddenly her
voice rose and burned like fire
bystanders who did not yet ascend to
immortality were incinerated just
through the sheer impact of her
insensitive fury over what she had just
heard her words seared the air and the
hall turned torrid for a moment father's
light looked like a spark swallowed by a
sea of wild fire she prompted us to
leave at once
father stood silent for a moment never
did someone dare question him he left
not saying another word it didn't matter
how misfigured
and atrocious her son was she loved him
nonetheless he was proof of the
resilient miracle that life is to her he
was perfect never in her dreams which he
abandoned her child and this my father
did not understand we went outside the
air still trembled from the uproar and
the ash fall got stronger still addled
with a ringing in my ear I tried keeping
up with father's pace until suddenly
strange lights caught my attention my
curiosity led me off track to a few
scorched Souls I remember one of them
approached me carefully with an oddly
familiar stare as if you recognized me
he lifted a strange creature from his
head and called it his son these people
were the proof of what would eventually
await those who play with fire on the
receiving end of the experiments was a
world of searing pain and darkness the
only soothing glimmer was an illusion of
the Sun induced by those fireflies a
local drug to those who sacrificed their
humanity in vain to keep the new fire
from fading
it wasn't until I looked into his hollow
eyes that I realized that those maggots
are a parasite yet
find their host to use their frail body
as a vessel so that they can hatch
suddenly my curiosity was disturbed by a
ghastly noise from below the temple
surface that went right through me it
sounded like a tormented growl and with
it came a rotten stench of intestines
when I flinched I fell into the ash and
burned my hands it truly was an eerie
place I winced and hastily caught up
with father the mortals who benefited
from the rebirth on the other hand
became the masters of their own fate but
swore to spend their eternity in
allegiance to their mother as sentinels
of her realm they didn't just build
walls to fend off outsiders they built
labyrinths upon labyrinths so the
unfamiliar world would lose themselves
in the spiraling Babel we were guided
all the way to their outer trade posts
where their land converged with ours
it was the path my kin had taken so many
years ago
when they first learned to walk upright
the upper districts served to provide
the underworld with water in exchange
for liquid fire to heat their forges
they supplied the outer world with their
most precious titanite a royal
blacksmith values so much i remember
hearing the clinking of prospecting and
the clanking of smithery from all around
the cave they must have grown so big
that they were able to forge whole
archways just like horseshoes on their
anvils it was here that father decided a
church must be built to bless these
lands with his faith and when whatever
slumbers beneath awakens ready to feast
and hell breaks loose again only then
would the Bell be wrong at the Sunburst
day as I write these notes that time has
now come and father heeds the core our
legions prepared ever since have
mobilized and will soon march off not
knowing what will await them alas my god
mother no matter what father hopes to
find down there no God deserves to be
consumed
no God deserves to be consumed chilling
words from the child who looks a lot
like Gwendolyn the identity of this
child is just one of the many hidden
details that support this piece and you
can read a ton of them over on Ricardo's
art station page it was a thrill to see
how many of these that I noticed on my
first reading and of course how many I
missed as well how many did you find so
after taking so much time to read
everything I don't really think I need
to tell you guys why this deserves first
place but I do want to let you know that
I didn't technically judge it just like
Ricardo's entry in the last competition
Ricardo and myself have started to work
on projects together
so to avoid bias this score was provided
solely by John Devlin who was my co
judge in this competition
so please please go and shower John's
social media with support as well
because these competitions could not be
judged alone and John is a really
talented artist in his own right
these competitions bring me so much joy
and they're always worth the money I
invest in them and I love reading your
comments about all the art so as I leave
you today I want to ask you all the
question
both the viewers and the artists what do
you think about an art book containing
all of the top entries maybe like the
top ten or even the top 20 so that we
can include more people in it it would
be a way way better visual medium than
YouTube is and I have a very talented
publisher in mind so let me know in the
comments and look out for the next art
competition
should it be Demon Souls or should it be
blood-borne stay tuned
you